[Musik]
die beste nebendarstellerin ist octavia
spencer in shape of water weil wenn man
sich den film ohne sie denkt war es die
schlechten guter film sein könnte ja die
klügsten köpfe des landes pinkl denn
dieser einrichtung den boden fallen und
in einem solchen selbstbewusstsein und
so eine hingabe an diese stimme freundin
spielt sie das wirklich mit kraft und
wucht ganz toll ich hoffe sehr dass wird
du wirst dich bedanken weil eine
gebildete frau ist mein größter der hat
immer seine körperliche anziehungskraft
aber die funktioniert schon lange nicht
mehr mal große große angst dass die
nebendarstellerin aus dem seidenen faden
gewinnt denn das wäre für mich ein
albtraum wie so ziemlich jeder ausgabe
in dieser film bekommen würde für mich
entsetzlich wäre einfach weil es ist
unglaublich absehbar und langweilig ist
bei den besten nebendarsteller bin ich
einem echten konflikt weil der film den
ich wirklich überragend finde in diesem
jahr triebel bauzeit er in missouri
gleich mit zwei besten nebendarsteller
in dieser kategorie drin ist entweder
ist sam rockwell oder woody harrelson
wobei ich vermute dass sam rogers
geschossen hat die verdammte axt
sie sagen zu haben gesetzeshüter auf
seinem eigenen revier nicht arm ist es
heißt woanders auch nicht das heißt da
muss ich mich jetzt einfach entscheiden
und ich gebe zu dass ich und auch
wiederum seit vielen jahren eine gewisse
faszination für woody harrelson bin ich
eher für ihr spielt ihr viel wirklich
mit heimsiegen halt dass man ihnen
wirklich um amtes eine seiner ganz
großen pop ups ist ich tue alles was ich
kann an den kern aufzuspüren ich finde
ihre bilder sind nicht besonders fair
der beste nebendarsteller ist willen
davor obwohl er nicht in meinem pony
mitgespielt hat aber vielleicht hat das
ja doch wir haben ihn nicht gesehen
[Applaus]
ihr könnt wieder fernsehen videos
glotzen köln was immer mehr flüge bannen
können die jetzt endlich sie ja auch mal
sein find ich auf einer best actress ist
sally hawkins und nicht frances
mcdormand sally hawkins frances
mcdormand nicht nur aus gesellige
hawkins tat sondern sogar ausgeführtes
mit lernen
wir sind so unterschiedliche
performances ich weiß gar nicht wie man
das entscheiden sollte wer da besser ist
oder wer schlechter hallo
er hat die dose geworfen welche dose was
ist mit dir schätzchen weißt du wer sie
geworfen hatten ein ganzes mcdormand wer
soll es sonst bekommen also besser als
sie in diesem film kann man eigentlich
nicht spielen
die story billboards leben davon dass
dass sie ihr gesicht in einem maße sind
sie diesen film einsetzt wie ich es
wirklich ihr gar nicht mehr zugetraut
hätte so wunderbar ich sie schon vorher
immer das ist erst der anfang
sally hawkins die vielleicht doch noch
mal einen tick anspruchsvoller ist
dadurch dass sie eben eine stumme spielt
und spricht und nur mit ihrem körper und
ihrer körpersprache
durch diesen film führt und diesen
ganzen film auch schuld muss man sein
[Musik]
hauptdarsteller sollte die salami wirken
der junge darsteller aus kombi war ja
nicht nur weil er so unglaublich schön
ist dann ein bei der er eine performance
hinlegt die an wirklich große ehrfurcht
ab verladen ist dass ich hoffe sehr dass
er das wird ganz junger kerl figur
hey content view ist es natürlich immer
dafür gut zu gewinnen aber hat im
seidenen faden mit gespielten also darf
er bitte diesen oscar nicht gegeben das
wäre wirklich einen link der wirklich
bester schauspieler war natürlich liev
schreiber als storm kind in meinem pony
aber weil er nicht nominiert ist dann
halt gary oldman weil ich das schön
finde wenn jemand dann die luft raus
lässt und dann muss er spielen
zeig ihnen seine wahren qualitäten seine
courage man schlechtes urteil schritte
gebe zu mir war das zu viel maskenspiel
aber ich würde man wiederum so sehr
gönnen und die nächste chance kriegt da
wahrscheinlich erst wieder in zehn
jahren also bitte also die haben
man kann mit einem tiger nicht
vernünftig reden nicht den kopf wenn
seine mal
[Musik]